CGI has become an unbeatable tool in
modern filmmaking to create like
Fantastical worlds breathtaking
Landscapes and incredible creatures that
would be impossible to achieve with
practical effects alone however despite
its many benefits CGI is not a foolproof
solution actually many directors from
classic movies like Star Wars Spider-Man
and Justice League regret the CGI in
their movies this 1999 film relied
heavily on CGI to create its titular
character a reanimated corpse with
Supernatural Powers unfortunately the
CGI used to create the character was
definitely not up to par and the result
was a stiff and unconvincing monster
that failed to impress audiences
directors Steven Summers talked about
his over-reliance on CGI in the film
saying that he wishes he'd used more
practical effects instead George Lucas
The Mastermind behind Star Wars
franchise famously used CGI in the
prequel trilogy creating entire worlds
and armies of digital creatures however
many fans felt that the CGI in the
prequels was overdone and detracted from
the film's storytelling and emotional
impact George Lucas has since been
pretty vocal about the fact that he
wishes he used more practical effects
emphasizing the importance of grounding
the films in a sense of reality Justice
League was heavily criticized for its
overuse of CGI particularly in the
scenes focused on the villainous
Steppenwolf the character was entirely
created using CGI and the result was a
poorly rendered and unconvincing villain
that failed to intimidate audiences the
director Zack Snyder has since stated
that he wishes he used a more practical
approach to the character even bringing
it down to a physical actor in a motion
capture suit one of the most common
issues with bad CGI in movies is that it
can detract from the emotion National
impact of a scene when audiences are
faced with poorly rendered CGI they are
less likely to become emotionally
invested in the story and characters
this was the case with the 2002 film
Spider-Man in particular the scene when
the Green Goblin attacks a parade and it
didn't go over well with the audience
director Sam Raimi has since expressed
regret over his use of CGI in the film
saying that he wishes the film had a
more grounded and realistic feel bad CGI
movies can also date a film very quickly
because the technology is obviously
constantly evolving and what looks
Cutting Edge today may look laughably
outdated in just a couple of years like
let's talk about the 1997 film spawn
which relied heavily on CGI to create
its demonic creatures the film CGI
effects were groundbreaking at the time
but they were soon considered pretty
cheesy looking director Mark AZ depay
later said he thinks using practical
effect would have given it a much more
Timeless quality oh let's be real Steven
Spielberg has very few movies to talk
badly about but according to him there
is something in Close Encounters of the
Third Kind that he really wishes he'd
cut one of the coolest things about the
movie is the aliens they're pretty
ambiguous for the majority of the film
and it wasn't really until the end that
they were really seen like at all
there's one scene in particular where
Steven Spielberg shoots inside the
mothership going through the entirety of
its interior he actually hated that he
did that because he thought it ruined
the Allure of the aliens he actually
ended up cutting it from the theatrical
release as far as CGI is concerned this
movie was filmed before it was a huge
thing in the industry but they did do
some Stellar special effects Artistry
inside the mothership again this was a
major bummer to Spielberg he hated using
all the special effects and wished he'd
cut it from the movie entirely it's
really hard to top the original film as
it truly set the bar for both digital
and practical effects unfortunately
Matrix Reloaded didn't quite live up to
the expectation the first one set the
CGI didn't really hold up and the fact
that it was heavily relied on makes it a
bit worse in particular the fight scene
between Neo and agent Smith looks like
something pulled from a 90s computer
screen and the car hopping highway chase
scene doesn't redeem it very much the
Practical stunts and effects were pretty
incredible especially for the time but
the excessive use of CGI definitely
makes for a disaster and disappointing
sequel needless to say fans were
definitely disappointed here's one
that's actually pretty insane a movie
that was done completely with practical
effects only to be replaced in entirety
with CGI and awful CGI at that the
original movie from 1982 is known as one
of the best examples of sci-fi and
horror to this day unfortunately the
2011 film of the thing is in no way
comparable to its predecessor a ton of
people who worked on the film when it
was done with practical effects were
pretty upset at the shift to CGI and
have major threats about that decision I
mean it's not a totally unwatchable film
but the monster effects were definitely
a major downgrade despite its many
pitfalls CGI remains a valuable tool in
the filmmaker's toolbox when used
sparingly and in service of story it can
create incredible worlds and creatures
that would be impossible to achieve with
practical effects alone unfortunately
though when filmmakers rely too heavily
on it it can have a detrimental effect
on the final product just ask the Green
Goblin at the parade what scenes do you
think should have been included in the
list